- What is it?
- Is there a place called Geordie Shore?
(techno music)
- A Geordie?
- Is it like a derogatory name for them?
- Like I thought it was fake at first
because it sounds so
close to Jersey Shore.
- Hey that's awful and
everyone's watching it.
We should do our version.
- This program contains strong language,
sexual scenes.
What?
- That is the most polite
warning I've ever heard.
- (laughs)
- There's the Snooki.
- This is the English language?
- I'm thankful for the subtitles.
- (laughs)
- Oh.
- Oh whoa you saw a dick.
- Oh shoot.
- Balls were out minute one.
- Gus being in the house
it was bound to happen.
- Gasping in the house it bound to happen.
- I mean he looks like he
could be from the Shore.
(glass breaking)
- Whoa.
- Whoa. (bleep).
- I'm lying there bangin' this blondie.
- I didn't understand a word of that.
- Can we also just backtrack and talk
about like how we just saw a dick?
Like on TV?
I don't think you could
get away with that here.
- No we don't get balls.
- We don't even get boobs.
- Don't give us a (bleep)
attitude ya dafty!
- Ya dafty (bleeps). (laughs)
- Aw yeah.
That looks like JWoww.
And that looks like Pauly D.
- They're all shirtless.
It's exactly like Jersey Shore.
(loud bang)
- Whoa!
- A fight just broke out.
- Get him!
- [Blonde] Jerry, Jerry, Jerry.
- Get him, get him.
- Wait why is there. Is there a tent?
- Yeah this is what the English are about.
- What was it about?
What was the argument about?
- The women look like a drunk person
was drawing an anime character.
- This makes Jersey Shore look scripted.
- Your willy!
- She said willy in a serious sentence.
- Trying desperately to get a shag and.
- Shag. That's a word we don't really say.
- I love her.
- Charlotte's just cuckoo.
- I think someone's drinking a full
bottle of wine on their own.
- [Both] Oh!
- [Blonde Woman] Oh!
- Oh! Oh boy, oh.
- They just need to take away like
all throwable objects in this house.
- I like Charlotte.
I'm so invested. I need
to know what happens.
- Not Charlotte. I don't like Charlotte.
- Let's get (bleep) mortal.
- Mortal.
- Oh Gary. No don't hook up with.
- Wait what about Charlotte?
- Gary get out of here.
- Charlotte was just
drinking a bottle of wine
with a straw so that's cool.
- Without the straw, out of control.
- Charlotte is now
fighting security guards.
- [Both] You slag.
- I'm learning colorful new insults.
- Yeah.
- [Blonde Man] Oh God!
- Oh penis dude.
- Ah he just helicopter dicked on camera.
- (gasp).
- Charlotte, Charlotte get out of there.
Get out of there Charlotte.
- No don't do that.
- I need a shower.
- I love this.
- It's like Jersey Shore on steroids.
- I know that you're not all like this.
- Do you think the Queen of England
likes this show?
- There's always gonna be
a handful of people
that like to be insane.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Because we all need good TV.